こんにちははじめ社長です今ですね結構話題になっていると思うんですけども
スナップチャットのフィルターがめちゃくちゃ凄いというか高性能でな
いろんなフィルターがあるんですよそれがすごい面白いってことなんでこのビッグ
ウェーブに乗るしかえーい
ということでやっていこうと思いますめっちゃいろんな人をやっててもう何回はネット
ではブームに行ってみたいですね
回転で実際にやっていきましょうまず出演するとこんな感じですね
[音楽]
今日もイケメンっていうのじゃなくてですね普通に写真をとってもそこそこもれる
っぽい感じではあるんですけども
じゃあまずで一重となるて twitter 感じでほんとそうだったんですよこちら
ですね
例えばああこれはでも何かありそうですね
これとかだとあっ
これなんかちょっとダンディーになる訳ですね僕が日入ると彼のこんな感じになるかも
すごく泣いてが普通にこういうのって正面しか反応しないんですけども横行向いても
しっかりとついてくるっていう
[音楽]
東するとぜひがいるとこんなになるんでしょうね
ワッハん
これもカッコいいと思うんですけどあとねすごいのはねはいこれこれ女性になれるん
ですよね
タッチ頑張って可愛い自分を見つければ
par
ん
何か欲しいなもう一歩と気がするなもう一歩もう一方
ならマッチングアプリとかのアイコンに時期そうな可愛い先生ですね
これが可愛いを追求する26歳の顔である
たぜー期待がからだなじゃあ胸とかこうやってもやばい音何やってんだ俺でもどうせ誰
だがなんかセクシーな女性な感じでしたよね
あやバッハ
キルトって
第かわいい私を見つければ
[音楽]
あっはぁっ
無理があるなちょっと26歳には無理があるかもこっちなん
大いやー oc なんかまだ
[音楽]
王莽もいいんですか
うん
胸はめちゃうそーめん例えばちょっとハゲきついんだよ横でこうなんか
[音楽]
あーやを惜しいな
あっほんと値段やって凄くないですかこんな僕でもこんな可愛くなれるんですよ
いやーこれが限界かなこれ面白い店数甲
方針はもう一歩足りないすっっ
入ってるわけですね他にもですねこちらが赤さになれるキャッツですね
ご覧ください hey
あああああああああ
これをですね何か僕あんまり変じゃないと思うんですよね顔が若いってこと
こうやって見るとでそんなに何か顔が平べったくなってるだけみたいな感じではある
なぁでもやっぱは腕
内の顔がぽっちゃりするとやっぱ若く見えるんですかねなんだそんなめちゃくちゃ変化
しているわけではないように見えてしまいますという感じでですね
こういろんなやつがあるんですけども実際僕だけやってもちょっとばかり
づらいと思うんでちょっと後輩何かよくやってみようと思います
なっちゃってくださでいきましょうバッハ
あっ入れもさあでも見て版サービスところは立つて確か bang 階外人ボール4で
じゃあ
作ってる
誰かはないですからああ
本当にあんないけ君こやつは目がさあすごい差あれは私はない
難波変わらないかもしれないなんてメールははい
[音楽]
ブーブー言っちゃあ日私がんばった
ファイルをとったんだろう俺たオレはーよっぱあぜっ立ってみんこさんは
アーマーほらやるやる言って頃えっ
ジャルジャルいろいろ人客は持っなんかちょっと雑感
ギャルギャルギャルピースううっ
4位そうよね売れるショップ行っていあーかわいいかわいいかわいい
提携地はん
ああああああ
すごいやばいよはさあ
はぁっはぁっはぁっパートとお酒ならカーチャンネル登録
おらずを見てもらう
すごいなんかは1小学生ぐらいうん
大
まあまあ
記述ギュたまってですね ua
うわぁ既存日ぶん殴りてぇすけど
えっ
ブーバー色そう
すごくない前版やっちまーすの全然強くないいそうじゃ
色 a すごいすごいすごいねうんすごいギャルやお前たてねまずすごいなぁ
ギャルやを怒るんですよね
ああああああ
どうぞああああ
a
[拍手]
してません
ん
def
tap ん
[音楽]